and adele you do do that thing you when
you bring out an album you bring it out
and you do the promo and you normally do
a tour or in this case it was gonna be
the vegas residency and then you vanish
yeah so
what are your plans for this vanishing
and do you know how long how long you're
going to be vanished for um
well i definitely will vanish again um
but i'm trying to like make a really
conscious effort to stop being so anal
with my privacy like i wouldn't say that
i'm still [ __ ] private
i'm trying to not always be two
completely different versions of myself
because it's exhausting like you know
switching on and switching off and some
of that so that's sort of why i'm sort
of like i go out for dinner a bit more
now even which i know sounds pathetic
but like what's the worst that could
happen nothing you know so um yes i will
be disappearing in terms of my music but
you might see a glimpse of me every day
and then i won't be in complete hiding
you know but do you disappear to like
recharge yeah and it takes me a while
yeah it really takes me a while like you
know it takes me about three years yeah
and then i got like read myself up to go
into the studio and then it takes me a
good year and a bit to finish an album
um but yeah but you know like i said i
would like to maybe have more children
so it'd be up to them you know because i
only just now feel like i've caught up
on my sleep from nine years ago when i
had my stuff yeah
so we'll see yeah
[Music]
you